[Music]
okay so what should we make up the
concept of events there are a lot of
anthropologists who would say we should
just throw this concept away completely
there's no basis for you and those
people are responding to what many
scholars call essentialist notions of
race there's something about this
particular group of people perhaps about
their you know anatomy or their
physiology or their brains or their
genes or something like this that
differentiates them from various other
groups of people if there's one thing
that we've learnt from biological
science and psychological science over
the last century it's that there's an
enormous amount of variation within the
groups that we've traditionally thought
of as races far more than there is
between the groups we've traditionally
thought of as races now it turns out
that if you look at things from a
genetic point of view the certain kinds
of molecular sequences are more common
in some groups than in other groups
that's because during the course of
human history these groups have been
separated from one another they haven't
intermarried and that's given various
chances for our various kinds of genetic
material to become prevalent in some
groups but not in others but the first
thing to say about that is that these
differences are trivial largely trivial
there are some cases as well known
diseases that tend to affect some groups
more than others that's that that is
that is not trivial to the sufferers but
by and large these differences are
perfectly trivial now about 15 years ago
a tremendously our brilliant study was
done by researchers at Stanford that
actually divided the human population
into groups that the research
just themselves called interbreeding
populations they didn't want to call
them races but very quickly the popular
press picked this up and I started
referring to them as races so you might
start out with the human population and
say ask the following question on the
basis of biological evidence gene
frequencies molecular frequencies of DNA
sequences in our in different
populations what would you get if you
wanted to divide the population to two
well you get actually Africans and are
most Asians are Central and Western Asia
and Europeans is forming one group and
the rest of the human population is
forming another group now what would
happen if you did it armed into three
groups well then you get the Africans
separated out from the Eurasian
population what would happen if you did
it for four groups 5 group 6 group 7
groups 8 groups name groups the first
five or so of these give you something
like sort of standard racial groups with
a few odd little twists the six gives
you as a six of these groups gives you a
tiny little population that has been
isolated because of mounting barriers in
Asia now those are genuine divisions
that have come out of our human history
and that are still present in the DNA
sequences of the genomes of various
people but whether we want to draw any
distinctions at all within the human
population it's completely up to us
remember how I did this I said if you
want to divide the human population into
two - three - four - five six seven this
biology will tell you how to make the
biologically significant decisions but
why should we want to do that is there a
point in doing that well sometimes there
is a point sometimes there's a point in
recognizing that certain people are more
closely related to other people
if you want to do medical
transplantation for example there is a
point in saying well you what you need
is somebody to give you a kidney who
comes from this particular group but
there are other people say this is just
the sort of stuff that breeds
discrimination and Prejudice as it has
in the past and there are the people who
say precisely because of that
discrimination we've had in the past
it's important to acknowledge these
groups so I want to say there's a
certain kind of biological phenomenon
that stands behind the historic process
of dividing people into racial groups
but actually these racial groups are
constructed by us it's we who decide
that we want to draw the lines and the
basis on which we should decide that is
an ethical basis we should decide how we
actually treat people most fairly so the
issue is really not whether there are
racial groups I mean we could think
about racial groups in as one two three
four five six seven and so on in
divisions in this initial human
population but it's a question of what
the divisions if any are useful from the
point of view of justice and fairness
and that I think is the right way to
think about race so is it scientific
well there's sort of something
scientific lurking in the background is
it socially constructed yes it's
socially constructed and the social
construction ought to proceed on the
best ethical basis we can find
[Music]
you